[Music]  knight c3 b5 and look at magnus's face  we miss it i'm wondering yeah he is not  happy at all  yes panko is looking to beat world  champion magnus carlson  this is a historical moment for him  it is just groundbreaking if he wins  this game  he will be one of the only players  to have a winning record against magnus  carlson  and as i mentioned earlier magnus  carlsen did not lose a class of  game chess for 125 games the guy  is hard to take down and in his first  opportunity  andre isapenko is about to do the  unthinkable  that's amazing that's just amazing  [Music]  historic moment he stopped the clock  18 year old grandmaster andrei yasipanko  just beat the world champion in a  classical game  [Music]  and look at him that he is exhausted  from the fight  that he just brought to the world  [Music]  champion  one of the best day in my life yes i  feel very great and i have nothing to  say